hi everyone i'm channing tatum here with  sandra bullock and daniel radcliffe we  have a really special announcement for  you we want to be the first to tell you  that thanks to our friends at fandango  you can watch our new movie the lost  city before it officially arrives in  theaters on march 25th through fandango  premiere when you say theaters do you  how he says it i actually i think i say  it's slightly wrong  again  theaters well as long as you are in a  theater  you will see lost city we'll be hosting  a special early screening of lost city  in  theaters nationwide on march 19th and  you can get your tickets right now over  at fenn and dango  this is like your book we're on the love  moore and dash adventure right now i'm  gonna help you out a little bit let's go  what are you doing don't do that come on  [Music]  you